welcome to this video or playing Chavo
let me tidy up my screen bhatia so Chavo
we are trying to sicilian a little bit
yeah i'm aiming for the time on off and
i'm getting it ok I don't know the
opening yet but I'm thinking of taking
this up and ok I know it's not like I
knew nothing because I have played it no
long time ago that opening with black so
this is the kind of thing that I still
remember as being kind of interesting
but I have not yet updated my knowledge
in any way so I probably yeah we'll make
some with some mistakes there because
I'm not up to date so um is he going to
go f4 hmm can I go h 4f 19 h 5 y can
play g5 maybe GFR that's an interesting
move let's try that it's a very
ambitious way to play but but
interesting trying to get this Queen on
this very noisy 5 square ok might ok
it's playing it very aggressive fashion
why not yeah i was thinking you could
have tried to just um yeah play play it
differently night over to c4 or
something like that ok um what what am I
doing here probably just d 60 after you
ok this this is good on me I think at
least I'm okay from here not like
brilliant but I get the knight to e5 and
this should mean that I'm in I'm in okay
shape so he wants to play
night over to see form okay that's no no
huge problem I think yeah the question
is what what am i doing now I probably I
can take yeah why not i can take
actually go ahead six just keep it like
that look out to everyone i can cover
conveniently my idea is to activate my
rook like Bishop g7 g8 rock g5 rook g5
this kind of thing hmm ok what about
your a 5 por now so I can try let's see
Rock rookie 5 or that start like that
you still cannot go before so might as
well activate that bishop mmm yeah I
wouldn't ever should go edge for I think
I should putting it on a dark square and
maybe I can I it's interesting i have
work g5 now my out mean otherwise roop
g7 so probably I should should play that
it's not a matter of huge choice but ok
this way I'm actually attacking a form
and now interesting if I go look f6 and
he's got a five ruge f2 wets bit of bit
oven it's unfortunate a little bit I can
take
all right it's a nice position at the
end if I go look f65 I'm taking a drug
takes rook f2 I can take on g5 that's
bad okay so okay then try that over to
e5 with the king
forgetting King e5 Andrew gave six this
kind of then I'm in very good shape
okay so let's go for that look at form
and picking up that porn yeah so still I
can take her now p 5 we should check see
for now I'm in a pin but hmm nothing
apparently dangerous inside okay now i
can't check here check again mm-hmm but
i don't really i cannot i can't take
stupid so i can just do this of course i
was just thinking i roped g2 and
somebody i came just wind up in the
piece so much simpler solution available
okay so he's continuing him um okay i
can check here or do I can wait is there
made somewhere if I go King f6 like Jack
let's not be fancy about it and play
normals let that does win and one point
is all you've got any game maybe this
King f6 was angling for made but check
Jack this is I think the the easiest way
to do it getting over with my king to
and to c5 check and pick up the rest of
the plants check
check-check
check jera not much to say this is kind
of a there's that kind of pointless ok
so how it interesting that the opening
here that some ideas of the opening
really worked quite well here this h5
idea this is a very crude idea crude
looking idea not just 94 if why does
playing a kind of a yeah non move like
this the night chief is already quite
embarrassing threatening mate and
threatening to take the bishop here with
the total damage of pawn structure so h3
is correct and now this is an idea thank
you trades the dark squares bishops and
wants to try to occupy the e5 square the
drawback is it's not so great in terms
of development and black can also be in
danger on the dark square as if things
go wrong the way it went or ever it was
quite nice um like this yeah g5 is a
risky move yeah quite clearly but I want
to know the ideas to go Queenie five
without being harassed by a fool but I
don't think that the way he played it
with air force is particularly this year
that this is particularly dangerous yeah
the computer says equal yeah thats its
maybe may be true with why displaying it
correctly but the way we we went i was
very satisfied like here this is a
position where um yeah it looks a bit
strange both sides have three palm
islands but i think that blacks ideas
are a little bit easier to realize i get
the bishop here to look at before I get
roped Jade
my only week looking porn f6 is covered
one point that is sometimes yeah how to
how to explain on yeah difficult to
grasp is that in this position Black is
effectively having an extra piece in the
game with the King the king only seven
is defending stuff like this and this
does a good job and this way basically
my king is protecting f6 ones and white
is using two roofs basically to just
bind one rukon age six the king only
seven is good anyway so I'm actually
have a look that i can use freely or
like on c5 and this is a somewhat
strange situation but in fact black it's
the more active part in this in this
position quite quite interestingly
enough but ok for I don't think that
this helps much around here it certainly
got quite quite convenient okay here i
had a 5mm that was a good move and the
comp gives this which is very strong
activating my rook very nice yeah i
could have played in a more forceful way
but this is keeping a good position yeah
and here okay i would have liked to play
rook f6 but he's got e5 that is yeah ok
this is what the computer gives but
that's too fancy i mean you can just get
the king over to e5 and this is good
yeah the engine is on minus 0.8 which
seems fair enough very difficult now it
says black wins so before probably
wasn't the best gives a five I am
desperado in this pawn yeah it's clearly
better for black but yes I have to wind
have to win it it's more difficult than
the game here it's really easy you just
pick up everything and okay this is yeah
I just I just I was thinking somewhere
here or whatever but this is just losing
a piece and shy
this black just wins yeah here he drops
a bishop but ok this is not not helping
in any way ever win even more policy in
the end game ok well thanks for watching